this is from the daily caller it says
establishment media has been
conspicuously silent on hunter biden's
alleged use of the n-word in text
messages obtained
by the daily mail and reported on
tuesday searching nbc news the
washington post cnn
and the new york times returns no
results related to the text messages
the story has been covered by the daily
caller forbes fox news and new york post
and other outlets um nbc news the
washington post cnn new york times did
not respond to requests for comment
just days after president joe biden
delivered an emotional anti-racism
speech in tulsa oklahoma the daily mail
published text messages
where hunter biden allegedly called his
white lawyer the n-word
and talked about his penis in one text
message hunter biden reportedly asked
his lawyer corporate attorney george
messiahs how much money he owed and said
n word you better not be charging me
hennessy rates
messiahs reportedly replied that made me
snarf my coffee
snarf i'm way more concerned with by the
use of the word snarf here
than the n word because i don't know
what that word means exactly
um hunter biden addressed his white
lawyer as
uh the n word with an a at the end
multiple times used phrases like
true dat n word and bantered i only love
you because you're black
okay and these were text messages i
think that date back to like 20 2018.
and uh as of the writing of this
daily caller article this story had not
been reported as they said
um in any of these mainstream media
outlets they just ignored it completely
it's not even like they reported it and
then buried it
or they just tossed off a a little short
two paragraph story and then buried it
no they've ignored it entirely
um and yeah so i i i'm kind of of two
minds
on this because on one hand
if this was don jr and
his text messages saying the n-word even
yeah
he's using the n-word here in a jovial
joking manner
and he's talking to and about a white
person
even so we all know that if this was don
jr or really any other prominent
conservative
and they were found to have used the
n-word in that context or any context
uh it would be a huge story and their
life would be destroyed and everything
else right we
we all know that and we've been told
many times by the cultural powers that
be
that context doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what uh context you use the word
and
papa john lost his job he lost
everything and is now a pariah
because he used the n-word just in
quoting somebody
else who used it and in the context of
using it he was actually he was critical
of the person
for using it and he lost his job for
that so
but we also know that papa john was uh
was i don't know if he's actually
republican but he was he was a suspected
republican
so there's a definitely a double
standard here that's for sure
however um
it also doesn't matter at all what what
words hunter biden used in a text
message exchange
i don't care at all it does not matter
and i also have to confess to you and i
know i'm going to put myself in the
minority a little bit
among conservatives and especially
conservatives in media
and i've been saying this since the
campaign i i don't
fully understand the right's
focus on hunter biden um
i think it's a bad political strategy i
don't think it works
because of course all the people on the
right who are sort of like feigning
offense over this they're not really
offended because they know who cares
doesn't matter at all um
but they're they're kind of feigning it
because they're trying to make a point
and i get that
but at the same time i just the the
focus on hunter biden i think is
is kind of foolish uh you're not gonna
land any hits
on joe biden by talking about his
loser crackhead son who's who's not a
public official
is not in the white house officially
right
or hasn't or should say has not been
given a job in the administration as far
as i know
you know donald trump gave a lot of his
kids
job official jobs in the administration
hunter biden hasn't been given that as
far as i know
um and uh we all understand that he's a
loser
so to keep going back to this well of
look at this other loser thing that
hunter biden did it just doesn't
nobody cares yeah the media is gonna
ignore it but
i'm kind of ignoring it too and i'm not
left-wing media but simply because i
don't think it matters
and whatever political advantage you
think you get by talking about hunter
biden i don't think it's there
i said this during the campaign with
with uh the final weeks
of the campaign and it's time to make
our our closing argument against joe
biden right
and what were so many people in
right-wing media doing
their closing argument was all about
hunter biden's laptop and i'm not saying
that that wasn't a story i'm not saying
there wasn't potentially a scandal there
i just don't think that that should have
been the closing argument and i said
that and i think i was proven right
[Music]
the arguments against joe biden should
be about joe biden himself and there's a
lot that can be said
and about his administration listen hit
that subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated